hello my name is jeff dunn from the
department of crop and soil sciences at
north carolina state university working
in peanut breeding and genetics
today i would like to present some of
our initial work on characterizing leaf
spot disease through image analysis of
advanced breeding and germplasm lines
within our peanut breeding program
the peanut research foundation which is
the research arm of the american peanut
council estimates that the annual losses
due to early leaf spot caused by paso
laura raccola and late leaf spot caused
by north of passalora personnada is
around 53 million dollars per year
to control leaf spot in the virginia
carolinas region alone it is estimated
that peanut farmers spend around 80 to
90 dollars per acre which equates to 17
million dollars per year when
considering the average production
acreage
some of the primary concerns regarding
leaf spot and the resistance these
diseases
is the pathogen overcoming plant
resistance some chemical resistance and
shifts from one pathogen to another
there seems to be a limitation on novel
chemistries and more of an emphasis on
combination fungicides which has the
potential of allowing the pathogens to
develop resistance to multiple fungicide
modes of action
from a plant breeding sense we cannot
control this level of resistance but
from a host level resistance we can
identify novel resistance genes within
our germplasm and breeding lines that
can help provide some protection if
fungicides start to fail
in addition if a resistance gene is only
effective against one or the other
disease
shifts in pathogen populations year to
year can easily overcome resistance
genes specific to one or the other
the peanut research foundation along
with the national peanut board
joined together to provide funding for
the peanut genome initiative
the goal of this initiative in phase one
was to provide a reference genome
sequence of the progenitor species and
cultivated species to benefit applied
peanut breeders in the development
selection and release of new cultivars
this phase was completed in 2019 with
the release of the arachisteronensis
hippiensis and hypogeogenomes
in phase 2 of the peanut genome
initiative the peanut research
foundation is funding four pillars of
applied research in an effort to utilize
the reference genomes produced in phase
one to develop germplasm and cultivar
releases for peanut improvement
the areas of interest under the phase ii
directive is improvement of disease
resistance aflatoxin research both pre
and post harvest and storage
drought tolerance and flavor improvement
for this research we fall under disease
resistance as we're trying to improve
and release cultivars with higher levels
of leaf spot resistance which was their
main emphasis for this category
within our breeding program we have
varying levels of resistance depending
on the resources in the specific program
and the cultivated breeding program the
one that results in cultivar releases to
growers we have a wide range of
resistant and susceptible reading lines
on the left this is a comparison of the
older cultivar
ncva 92r
and a newly developed breeding line
n16021
relative to the performance in the
cultivated breeding program
the wild species breeding program has
way more resistant germplasm lines
on the right the line in the center is a
newly developed interspecific hybrid
between an older cultivar gregory and a
wild species diploid arachis diagoy
the level of resistance is greater than
any line in the cultivated breeding
program however the agronomic properties
are extremely low
on an overall view of the two breeding
programs there is clearly a difference
in the level of resistance to leaf spot
represented in these drone images
on the left is our advanced leaf spot
trial clearly a number of lines are
brown and completely defoliated under
intense leaf spot pressure with no
applications of fungicides on the right
the wild species shows consistently high
levels of resistance to leaf spot under
the same leaf spot pressure with no
applications of fungicides
these two images were taken on the same
day the main sources of resistance that
the cultivated breeding program is using
for early and late leaf spot resistance
comes from a ractus cardinal ci and
arrakis diagoy
in the development of the cultivar
bailey a wild species introgression line
from miractus carnacion was used to
develop
no3o81t which eventually became bailey
so we know that it's possible to
transfer these beneficial resistance
genes into superior yielding lines in
the cultivated breeding program
currently our efforts to identify and
select for leaf spot resistance are
somewhat limited to a subjective
evaluation of breeding plots by the
peanut breeder
these ratings aren't as straightforward
as you'd think and often can be
compromised by changes in weather
raters replications field size etc
for leaf spot we rate on a one to nine
scale where one means the line is
resistant or doesn't have any visual
lesions or defoliation
5 means it has significant leaf spot
lesions but no noticeable defoliation
and then 9 which means the plot has been
completely defoliated or reduced to
vines
in the image to the right i have a
peanut leaf
that shows symptoms of early and late
leaf spot
early leaf spot is depicted as having
light brown lesions with a yellow ring
or halo however the halo isn't always
present
late leaf spot are more darkly colored
and generally lack a halo with prominent
sporulation on the underside of the leaf
surface
when taking ratings on the plot level
it's incredibly difficult separating out
early versus late leaf spot percentages
visually therefore our ratings simply
become an overall percentage of lesions
when it comes to taking ratings on plots
typically the ratings are relative to
other plots
when i take a rating on leaf spot i
usually walk the entire field and get a
mental representation of what i would
consider to be a five rating
i then continue looking at the plots
until i'm confident i could identify all
ranges of the rating scale
i'll give you an example here i'm
suggesting the plot on the far right is
considered a five with only knowing this
rating could the ratings of the other
plots be identified
here are my thoughts
based on the rating of a five i might
rate this plot a three in comparison the
plot is healthy and had minor symptoms
of leaf spot
the one next to it is nearly completely
defoliated so i'll rate it in eight
the final two plots i would rate a four
because of a slightly higher leaf spot
lesion percentage and the one in the
middle the arrakis diagonal line i would
probably rate a one because it has no
visual symptoms of leaf spot and would
be considered resistant
the rating may differ due to changes in
weather between raiders or across the
field because we're human
in order to get a consistent
representation of leaf spot infection a
high throughput method of evaluation
needs to be developed
the overall importance of taking good
consistent ratings is that it helps us
to map the genes responsible for
resistance so that we can design genetic
markers that will identify families and
or lines with those important genes and
then use them in our program to make
selections on the left is a
representation of a single
introgression block and multiplexed casp
or pace assay that we use for selection
purposes within our program
for a single assay we can select for
fixation in green or enrichment yellow
for the next generation of development
for an integration block we design
flanking markers with similar
fluorescence patterns after the same
number of pcr cycles to bring
intragression blocks conferring
resistance from the wild species program
into the cultivated program and finally
we can stack multiple single marker
assays together with similar
fluorescence patterns after the same
number of pcr cycles to select for
multiple traits
on the right is a simple schematic of
the ncsu peanut breeding and genetics
programs breeding pipeline we make
crosses and we send those to puerto rico
to get an extra generation of
development when the lines come back we
progeny test them in the field for
disease resistance in this case leaf
spot resistance we identify the best
families from the field and pair it with
the marker results select the plants
with the best pods for those families
and then repeat the cycle after several
cycles these lines that advance to our
yield trials and hopefully one will be
selected for release
so based on this information we
developed a project with the following
objectives
the first is to identify objective
methods for evaluating leaf spot both
early and late leaf spot for improving
phenotyping and data quality
the second is to produce a high
throughput protocol for objective
methods for evaluating leaf spot
the third is to evaluate and genetically
map early and late leaf spot resistance
among the breeding families and lines in
the north carolina state university
peanut breeding and genetics program
and finally use these identified genetic
markers to select families and lines in
the cultivar development program with
increased resistance to leaf spot and
this can be through marker assisted back
crossing or selection for the purposes
of this presentation we'll be reporting
results for the first objective only as
this is an ongoing project
the data that i'm going to show today
represents some of the preliminary work
that was conducted in 2019 and 2020
in 2019 representative samples of
commonly grown cultivars within the
breeding program leaf spot trial were
assessed using developed scripts in fiji
which is just image j to separate the
visual rating into their sub components
so what we wanted to know is one could
we effectively scan the tissue collected
and differentiate between early and late
leaf spot using the images alone and in
addition
could we then use the tissue scans to
estimate an overall percentage of leaf
spot infections on leaf tissue and then
two
could we track using uav imaging over
time the relative canopy loss due to
leaf spot infection that could be
attributable to defoliation
to do this work eight leaves were
randomly selected per plot and then the
32 leaflets were scanned on an epson
scanner for analysis
the canopy cover was captured using a
dji mavic 2 pro drone which comes
stocked with a one inch sensor and
images were stitched together using
agisoft's meta shape
so it turns out it's way more difficult
to separate these two diseases using
basic thresholding
the issues include one whether each leaf
spot can be accurately identified and
how long it takes to go through each
leaf sample
two the resolution in the image may not
allow us to accurately differentiate the
spots
three the thresholding cutoffs that sort
the clusters leave spots
may be too similar
and four the population pressure of each
disease in a given year may change for
example the peanut pathologist here
estimated that late leaf spot infection
was around 95 percent in 2019 among the
two diseases
in order to attempt at differentiating
these diseases
more data collected on the specific leaf
spots is needed in order to develop a
better training model for accurately
classifying early and late leaf spot
that being said getting a percentage of
lesion areas pretty straightforward
the fiji script is designed to threshold
the leaf spots and the entirety of the
leaf surface separately
the ratio between these two pixel totals
gives us our leaf spot estimates on the
leaf surface
the script is automated to run through
each of the images collected per plot
and can calculate the final leaf spot
percentage
similarly the drone images help us to
estimate canopy cover changes during
heavy leaf spot pressure
the top and the bottom rows of images
represent pre and post leaf spot onset
respectively in the top row images were
taken on september 6th and in the bottom
row images were taken on october 8th
prior to harvest the first column shows
the thresholding across all of the plots
the second column shows a similar image
crop to our gridding of each individual
plot and the final column shows the
final image threshold
using these two canopy scores we can
estimate a change in canopy cover that
we're calling defoliation
in some instances when a plot is
relatively unaffected by leaf spot the
defoliation score can actually be
negative due to the continual or
unaffected growth
we can then apply this method to our
entire breeding program in the field we
grew out 220 lines in 2020 and used this
approach to get leaf tissue and
defoliation estimates for each plot on a
bi-weekly basis during heavy leaf spot
pressure
we additionally have yield data
collected on these untreated plots
along with plots that were treated with
fungicide but this data will not be
presented here
presented are the results obtained using
the previously described methods
collected in 2020 on the 220 breeding
and germplasm line selected from the
program
on the left is a figure of 26 lines that
were whole genome sequence for another
project for developing a high throughput
genotyping platform for our program
moving forward
these lines were chosen based on several
traits of interest including resistance
to leaf spot
these differences in the bar chart
represents the visual ratings taken on
these genotypes prior to harvest
on the right are some basic statistics
describing the different evaluation
methods including the tissue scans alone
the drone or defoliation score alone or
a combination of the two using the first
principal component when compared to the
visual scores
in each instance the evaluation type was
highly correlated with the visual rating
in addition the visual score which again
is a one to nine rating
was also modeled using logistic
regression to determine the predictive
potential of each evaluation type
the logistic model produces overall
concordance scores which is the model's
predictive potential
and odds ratios for each evaluation
parameter
the concordance scores compares pairwise
scores across the data set to determine
if the probabilities associated with
being in a higher visual score are true
for each pair paired test
for the odds ratio this is determining
the odds of being in a higher visual
score given an increase in the
evaluation unit
if you look at the models evaluated
tissue alone drone alone pc1 and the
full model of tissue plus drone there is
an increase in concordance when
considering more parameters
but it seems the pc one that explains
around 79.1 percent of the variation is
similar to the full model
that being said there isn't much of a
difference in concordance when using
tissue or defoliation data alone either
the odds increase
with the number of parameters too
for tissue alone there is 1.3 times the
odds of being in a higher visual score
when the percentage of leaf spot surface
area increases which makes sense
under the pc-1 were 10 times more likely
to be in a higher visual score when the
two components tissue and drone increase
together
our future work on this leaf spot
evaluation method is funded through the
usda nifa plant breeding program
and the work over the next two field
seasons will be conducted by my phd
student cassie newman
the work that we're doing in the field
this year consists of multiple rating
systems timings and data collection
types i will be evaluating the plots for
leaf spot on the previous 1 and 9 scale
this will be done in a weekly manner
cassie will be evaluating the plots
using the low throughput objective
method of drone imaging for defoliation
and tissue collection for lesion counts
and leaf spot differentiation
lastly we'll also be collecting the high
throughput images and developing an
algorithm to rapidly analyze the images
for instant leaf spot ratings using cell
phone capture
the collection timing will essentially
be from august through harvest in
october
here we're diagramming our high
throughput method that just uses drone
and or cell phone images to rapidly take
ratings on both defoliation and leaf
spot lesions
the idea here is to evaluate the 220
lines in the field using drone imaging
and can currently walk through the plots
taking cell phone images the images will
be instantly uploaded where an image
software with a customized algorithm
would be waiting to analyze the plots
in addition we're going to evaluate
using canopio to determine the
effectiveness of this application in
detecting leaf spot lesion counts and
canopy changes
using these approaches ratings can be
objectively taken and in less time
if the analysis is completed i can then
look at the data and make selections
within these lines for further
development
ultimately what we're hoping to achieve
is to pair our newly developed
genotyping pipeline which capitalizes on
whole genome sequencing and in-silica
digestion for optimized gbs
developed by cassie newman to high
quality leaf spot ratings in order to
identify regions or inter introgression
blocks that are influencing leaf spot
resistance
with that i would like to thank all of
those organizations that sponsor our
research
particularly the national peanut board
the peanut research foundation
severn peanut company in hampton farms
and the usdars and nifa programs and i
want to thank you for your time
if you have any questions regarding this
project
please feel free to ask or you may call
or email me thank you